let's continue speaking to people from
the audience we take calls on the Friday
show via Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord I want to go next to Freddy from
Monterey Freddie from Monterey welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
what can I do for you
Freddie from Monterey
can you hear me yes I can
hey um thanks for taking my call uh it's
a question um
here in California and I am going in two
weeks to Wisconsin to a family wedding
and I know a very important election
just happened I believe that was today
so earlier this week in Tuesday on
Tuesday there was a liberal Supreme
Court Justice elected to the Wisconsin
Supreme Court and this makes the court a
liberal court for the first time in 15
years major implications for abortion
rights gerrymandering maybe even the
2024 election
right which is great yeah I was looking
at that the whole gerrymandering thing
and um
absolutely insane hell the Republicans
can do that
um
but I was just wondering you know I'm
going there and I'm
realizing that a lot of the family uh
in-laws family that I'm gonna be around
probably don't have the same views as me
and somebody hadn't made a joke about us
coming from California and they were
going to let us know and this and this
and this so I was just I know you like
to you have a little pointers on
um
how I should go about
what I say you know and like try not to
get in the arguments you know it's like
my wife's family and stuff I I don't
well here are my suggestions I actually
wrote a guide about this and if you go
to davidpackman.com guide some people
call it a white paper some call it a
guide this is free it's like 10 pages
it's called building arguments without
Burning Bridges and it'll give you a lot
of ideas and fundamentally the decision
you have to make is
what sort of relationship do you want to
have with the folks you're visiting and
that will kind of inform how
confrontational or adversarial you want
to be but yeah free guide available on
that topic davidpackman.com guide
oh great that's cool okay yeah just I
mean I'm pretty excited about you know
the results that happened over there and
I'm like oh yeah I'm going to Wisconsin
this is great but then I'm like oh
should I show how excited I am you know
it's like I gotta just play it by ear I
guess I think that's the smartest thing
all right cool well that's about it all
right thanks Freddie Freddie's got a lot
going on there and headed to Wisconsin
very soon which I'm sure will be a very
very powerful trip